geodis c'est la première faute de dieu
peuvent l'excité
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si vous mettez moi musique l'eau en fait
ce que tu veux daniel
bouvet et mettre la langue tu l'avais
fait en danse
puis après quand on sait quand on s'en
est d'ailleurs monté regarder
[Applaudissements]
non
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
semblant
c'est vrai des
[Rires]
mamans
on m'a volé on est abonné aux dires de
me roger
ouégnin on n'y
avait pas
voilà et bon bah c'est bon
alors si je peux me permettre elle a
commencé d'abord mettre la langue s'est
dit que ça dépendrait ça m'a fait
plaisir
franchement tu veux
franchement je vais tenir un daniel si
j'étais pas en couple vous serez des 71
malheureusement là tu vois c'est
bien sûr qu'elle a émis elle voit bien
là il a parlé pendant deux heures
tu vas pas galea on en rigolait elle est
blanche elle est allée passer par toutes
les couleurs turquoise lèche de kovy des
frères dans la colère y avait des bandes
de toupah
sam est un parent était très douce avait
faute à des banderoles être
là et m'ont donné envie de
plaire aux fans de l'univers des scops à
jamais
y a toujours été très courtois à ton
égard que sûr c'est que c'est manière
non mais oh ça va quoi est très douce